ethiopian government soldiers took the
city of mckele
the regional capital of tigre without
much fighting
their enemy the tigrayan people's
liberation front appeared to have
decided
not to put up much resistance
after taking full control over mckealy
our forces are now pursuing and hunting
anti-peace elements hidden in holes
the government says its forces now
control all of the region
ethiopian state television showed
weapons that it said the tplf had hidden
in churches
but questions remain where are all the
tplf's fighters
and its substantial stocks of military
hardware
and is it equipped to fight an
insurgency as it did once before
successfully in the 1970s and 80s
its leaders have said it will keep
fighting
ethiopia's government says it no longer
has popular support
this guerilla warfare component of tpr
left this is part of
the history that they have enjoyed with
the old guards as well
there isn't popular support for this
kind of thing within the region
prime minister abi ahmed came to power
two years ago
taking over from nearly 30 years of tplf
dominated rule
reforms he introduced have reopened old
conflicts
ethiopia has seen growing tensions
between the peoples of its various
regions
and the federal government the concern
is that that on some of these core
issues of autonomy of tigray and the
self-determination of the tigran people
that is actually quite a lot of support
for the tplf despite tigran concerns
about the party
more than 40 000 people have fled to
neighbouring sudan
some of them say they don't feel safe to
go home as long as federal government
forces are in control
the government says its military
operation is over
many others fear the conflict may have
only just begun
malcolm webb al jazeera